So if Miriam really does have a friendly personality. What we mean by that is
that her threshold for acting friendly is lower than most people. So here we
see Miriam's threshold for acting friendly. She's more likely to act friendly
in different situations as compared to not acting friendly. On the other hand,
we have Biriam, who has a very high threshold for acting friendly, meaning it
takes him a lot more to be nice to someone than it would for Miriam to be nice
to someone. So this is one trait that makes Biriam and Miriam unique. So traits
change our threshold for behaving. And make us more likely to behave in ways
consistent with with the trait. Such as being friendly. And less likely to
behave in ways Inconsistent with the trait, for example, being hostile or mean.
So just because it takes a lot more for Biriam to be friendly, it doesn't mean
that he can't be friendly and just because Miriam is usually friendly doesn't
mean there aren't situations where she's not friendly. Their traits make them
more likely to behave in a way that's consistent.